[Music]
and tonight from sunday to monday it was
that time of the year again the golden
globe winners were honored for the 79th
time a special novelty this year was the
digital awards ceremony without any
glitch and glamour instead the winners
were announced quite unspectacularly via
social media in addition to the
individual winners the unofficial
ranking among the numerous streaming
services is particularly interesting
after all netflix has been while the
biggest winner in recent years this year
however netflix was beaten out by hbo
which won the most trophies with a total
of six on the acting side will smith and
king richard and nicole kidman being the
ricardo's won best actor and best
actress in motion picture drama
respectively the most prestigious golden
globe for the best motion picture drama
was won by the novel adaption the power
of the dog squid game actor oyunxu also
won an award in the best supporting
actor category on the musical level the
jury was convinced on the one hand by
han zimmer's compositions for dune as
the best movie score and on the other
hand the duo of billy ellis and finney
zicotta was awarded for the best movie
song they were responsible for the new
bond track the golden globes are often
considered a precursor to the oscars
globe winners have a good chance of
winning another trophy we are all the
more eagerly awaiting the academy awards
which will be held on march 27
2022 on friday last week the disney plus
twitter channel published that the
upcoming pixar movie turning red will be
released on the streaming service only
and not in theaters the reason is likely
to be the ongoing pandemic which makes
it difficult for vera young viewers in
particular to watch the film in movie
theaters upon release due to possible
restrictions the plot revolves around 13
year old girl melee who at first glance
was nothing more than a normal teenager
she hides her feeling for a crush is a
fan of a rising boy band and of course
wants to come across as being cool at
all costs everyone knows the problem of
turning red at awkward moments but melee
has hit it much harder every time other
people would get red cheeks she
transforms into a giant red panda it's a
pretty tough faith that she has to learn
to deal with behind the scenes there is
quite a bit of trouble as a lot of pixar
staff members aren't too fond of
disney's move to skip theaters various
team members who of course wish to
remain anonymous are expressing their
displeasure and disappointment as they
had all hoped that turning red would be
the great comeback to the big screen on
the other hand they also show
understanding after all when it comes to
some matters tough decisions have to be
made their next hope would be the pixar
film light year which is due in june
this year turning red however will be
released on march 11 2022 already
the batman fans won't have to wait much
longer for its theatrical release it is
therefore all the more pleasing that we
are regularly receiving new images from
warner brothers during the important
promotional phase in the last few days
some new pics have appeared on which not
only two well-known villains but also
the dark knight himself can be seen
first let's take a look at the bad guys
ign shared a snapshot of the riddler and
the penguin last sunday the shot of the
riddler in particular caused some buzz
in the movie community after all so far
you have barely been able to make other
batman antagonists in the teasers and
trailers however it is not only the fact
that you can finally see the riddler in
all its glory but especially the way in
which the riddler is presented that has
caused some confusion on the picture he
looks clearly different from the role of
jim carrey in batman forever for example
the situation is similar with the
penguin we already know him from all the
batman movies in particular danny
devito's weird version from batman
returns comes to mind colin farrell's
portrayal actually looks more like a mob
boss from a martin sco [ __ ] film so all
in all we can say that both villains
look much more realistic and less like
an adaptation from the comics well
that's a good or bad thing will only be
seen upon release anyway two more
pictures appeared via usa today on one
of them we see robert pattinson in a
gloomy scene the second much more
exciting picture on the other hand shows
batman and catwoman in front of a
picturesque skyscraper setting as we've
known since late last year from a
synopsis by cinemax in the batman bruce
wayne and selena cow are childhood
friends which of course should provide
some emotional tension between the two
if you still haven't had enough of the
images you can look forward to more
snapshots directly from warner where you
can see all the characters mentioned
again from a different perspective as
well as a few beyond the scene shots in
summary these are some great pictures
that whet your appetite for the
blockbuster the batman is scheduled for
release on march 4th 2022
last winter amazon started production on
the third season of the boys now it is
finally known when a season start can be
expected to the joy of many fans the
waiting time is kept short because the
season will be available on amazon prime
video as early as june 3rd 2022
fittingly the first teaser was released
which is expectedly short but definitely
makes you eager for more you can see
anthony stars homelander and aaron
moriarty starlight obviously in the
headquarters of the 7 where especially
homelander is in the flurry of camera
flashes of the reporters the longer the
scene goes on the more confused and
serious he looks and it is quite likely
that the focus on the upcoming season
could clearly be on homelander in
addition to him and starlight the other
main characters will also be returning
to the screen including call urban ass
butcher jack quaid as huey and dominique
mceligad as queen meth together they
will once again bring plenty of action
center and black humor to the series
while they will also be joined by some
newcomers for instance we will get to
see supernatural story jansen eccles as
soldier boy and the walking dead star
actress laurie holden as crimson
countess they are members of another
super team called payback children eric
kripke is in charge of production while
the infamous duo of seth rogen and evan
goldberg will also keep an eye on the
same thing the first three episodes of
the third season of the boys will be
released on june 3rd after which a new
episode will be released every week
most people are familiar with the final
destination movie series especially in
the 2000s the brutal and sometimes
somewhat trashy films enjoy great
popularity the fifth and last part was
released in 2011 more than 10 years ago
now the ball seems to be set rolling for
a new installment as the hollywood
reporter reveals that no way home
director john watts is taking over
production of the upcoming blockbuster
as we have known since the beginning of
2021 another final destination party has
been in the planning for quite some time
and now it is also become known that it
will not be released in theaters but
exclusively on hbo max the previous
plans of screenwriters patrick melton
and marcus dunsman have been completely
scrapped and instead watts came up with
his own idea which will be implemented
by new writers laurie evans taylor and
guy busick instead of being a true
sequel this will be more of a reboot no
further information has leaked out yet
but we are excited for a new final
destination movie after many years
so far there are two movies in the
indonesian action series the raid the
last one was released in 2014 again
directed by gareth evans fans have been
waiting for the announced remake for
quite some time now and as deadline
reports it is gradually moving forward
streaming giant netflix recently
acquired the rights to the raid and
announced a few new additions in the
process evans is no longer in toxic
director after the two original parts
instead the expandables 3 director
patrick hughes is now to direct the
remake and simultaneously write the
script with james beaufort behind the
scenes action legend michael bay is also
involved as a producer which is quite
fitting for a film like the raid he is
joined by aforementioned gareth evans
who will also be keeping an eye on the
production the original is set in
indonesia where police officer has to
brutally make his way through a
high-rise full of criminals
while the storyline was rather subtle it
featured brilliantly choreographed
martial arts scenes and very bloody
confrontations the planned remake is
supposed to keep the spirit of the
original but the location of the action
will be moved to philadelphia and the
usa where undercover agents of the de
have to fight their way through a house
full of members of a drug cartel we are
definitely excited and looking forward
to the raid remake although it is not
yet known when the film will be released
on netflix
for those of you who haven't seen it yet
this week we recommend our original for
avatar 2. in only 11 minutes you will be
up to date with the latest news on this
sequel also for fans of apocalyptic
action films the third trailer for this
sci-fi movie moonfall is definitely a
must-see
[Music]